hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to fortnite battle royale
now they just released a new game mode
called 50 v 50
which literally means you pit 50 players
against 50 players
in fortnite which is kind of a pub g
clone not
100 but pretty much and then when you go
to the island
there's a bunch of crafting that you can
do while you're also trying to fight
to survive so i'm gonna go in here
probably suck
probably die my team is probably gonna
lose but bottom line 50 v
50 mode is stupid fun imagine if you had
just
a huge bunch of your buddies all not
able to talk to each other but somehow
hive minding your way into building
bases killing other players
and just beating the snot out of each
other all day long and then you kind of
have what 50 v
50 is uh and if you want to give an idea
about the game it is pretty much pub g
uh can't jump off into the ocean well
this game's stupid and i hate it so
we're just waiting to get on the bus one
thing i like about it the wait time to
get on the bus
ways way way way better all right
so this is the battle bus and i'm not in
a squad
because i don't want them jabbering in
my ear about it but i'm not in a squad
and uh in the future i may play this
with bob and wade and whoever else wants
to play but
for right now i kind of got to just
take my time and uh
i don't know i just kind of got to take
my time and hope for the best oh
boy
[Music]
all right so same ordeal i've got a
i have to uh glide my way down
and i don't know where my teammates are
all gonna go
until they land now all 50 of my
teammates could be anywhere on the
island which means that i could land in
the
middle of nobody and die horrible death
which is exactly what i'm probably gonna
do because i don't see
anybody i see nobody
i got nobody by my side
i'm going to go the other side of loot
lake for some reason and kind of like
rambo this and by rambo this i mean i'm
going to be the guy that rambo usually
shoots
and die like instantaneously there's
something in the middle there's
something at loot lake here
i don't know so the trick is if there is
a trick to this game
to uh try your best to smash in roofs
because that's where all the loot is
for some reason not 100 sure why anyway
so ignore the squiggly nature of this oh
good nothing that's
excellent oh boy so you just uh the
pretty much the premise is
pretty much everything is destructible
in this world and you just make do with
what you got
and you oh that's a trap but not a gun
if i don't get a gun in this goddamn
building i am
so um oh good a pistol
perfect exactly what i was hoping for
okay there's something here
that sound means that there's something
probably a chest of some sort
in this room ah
ah goody goody gumdrops that's a little
marginally better okay where's my team
i am very far from where i need to be i
am very boned okay
let me oh that's not what i meant to do
all right well
it is what it is so
all right well i got a gun got some
mammal got bandages and i got no hope
so let's make our way to the circle
because it's going to be like pub g it's
going to close in on me
and i'm going to die well i just alerted
everybody to my position
and i am very slow through this marsh if
anybody spots me
i'm as good as dead
just walking in the lake
sticking out like a sore thumb let me
stop
yeah smell yeah this is the good stuff
yeah this is still the mood everybody
okay so i don't know oh god i must not
be close enough to be able to find my
teammates
see that's the problem if you don't get
close
you're going to be dead and i looks like
i'm going to be dead my teammate
my team is not doing well 27-38 oh i
am just boned i am so
i am so unbelievably boned if
it was a measure on a scale to put how
boned i
am i can't describe it because it's off
the charts of how much bone ridge
i'm currently in oh boy i think my team
is getting annihilated left and right
which is
never a good sign oh boy i'm so boned
i'm so boned well technically speaking
i'm in the circle which is
okay i guess not great ooh what's that
a shield potion cause that makes sense
sure why not
yeah i don't understand how shield
potion works like
some kind of magic going on there or is
that just like energy being
is that pure radiation being put into my
bones
is probably not a good thing okay 24 to
34 and i'm just a lone wolf out in the
middle of nowhere
oh oh store my shrinking well the good
news is no one's gonna expect me coming
from this direction the bad news is
they've got 34 people
which isn't really good odds i'd say
usually that ends up with me being dead
on the road again
out on my own and on the road again ooh
is that a teammate
oh it's a teammate oh out on his own
dude i found another rambo
well that's that doesn't bode well for
me but
well i hear that where are you at oh
so here's the trick of this thing you
can
build up
and ah [ __ ] oh wait here we go
got it nope didn't get it
ah cry minnie christmas
crime any crap miss it's oh geez oh boy
okay well all right hang on oh this is
embarrassing
oh this is the worst type of
embarrassing there we go all right
what did i get nothing this is not worth
my trouble
great okay all right well moving on
glad i stopped for that [ __ ] what are we
looking at oh i got some teammates over
here even though they're probably not
gonna survive but i might as well join
up with them because my survival
odds go up exponentially if i don't go
on my own
oh i'm just a walking bag of ammo for
anybody that kills me
but okay at least i know my lot in life
at least i don't have to reach
too high try to exceed my own goals i
know exactly where i'm going to be and
that is in the realm of suck
and if i'm along this river at least my
body will float down and feed some of
the wildlife
that's all one can really hope for so
where in the hell are
the rest of the team oh good they're
coming to us
oh good you know how i said good i
actually meant not good
the opposite of good the anti-good maybe
i could hold this bridge i guess
that'd be a thing i could be the bridge
troll none shall
pass oh
ow i've been downed no my ass
geez all right well like i said i was a
walking loot tray couldn't even kill
that one guy
oh this is going badly for us you know
what i'm gonna i'm gonna leave this
match
and uh i'm gonna try this again that one
that one didn't go well
right off the get-go so let's hope that
there's more hope for me later
all right let's do this a little
differently i'm actually gonna get some
teammates in my squad and hopefully i'm
not gonna die immediately because i
won't be on my own and no one will love
me i don't know probably not
good news off the bat papa chuck is
disconnected which is
always great okay all right let's do
this i don't know where we're going but
okay
now that is a thump and bass all right
so the question is
oh my teammate already launched well i
that doesn't bode well for me oh boy my
squad is across the entire map from each
other that's
always good i like that
uh oh that's an enemy player that's also
an enemy player ah
i've boned myself i will leave excuse me
i must
my people require me excuse me man
you can go fast and far away holy [ __ ]
okay all right well i'm here now boy
ooh that is an epic something
what is this magical device oh slurp
hey guys i got slurp juice i don't know
what that did
but uh i'm i feel real slurpy guys
i feel right as slurpy whoa hey hey come
on now
oh wow what's going on here ow
well that's just rude no you no no
no no no no no
[ __ ]
[Music]
well my slurp juice did me a whole lot
of nothing
oh i'm asian now
great two gigantic teams face earth
nearby teammates are marked in green
after they've landed
i don't know where my team is going good
day folks
and a good day to youtube i always like
when people are polite right off the bat
just let you know folks i'm up to it's
like my third game ever in the game
so oh don't worry me too i'm patently
terrible at this
shall we stick together then yes let's
stick together let's all go to anarchy
dude
oh hell yeah all right folks let's say
when we jump out
oh [ __ ] i already jumped weak right now
yeah i
just jumped straight down oh uh
following you folks
how's your guys's day going oh you know
same old same old not too bad mommy's
gonna be my birthday soon so
[ __ ] off i ain't doing [ __ ] today and
tomorrow
oh happy birthday thank you folks
let's hope a lot of teammates landed
over here
let's hope too is there any uh weapon
class that you guys are better with or
nah i just usually prefer to have
anything yeah i can kind of rock any gun
i play fairly often so i mean i'm not
the best but i'm not the worst
oh my boy
yeah i got one down
nick i'm gonna need a status report
where are they currently at oh my boy
nick dead
oh nick dead alright oh yeah the girl in
the house with a shotgun
open the door and she was there standing
got me
oh my apologies nick i wish i could have
saved you you seem like a nice person
yeah what a rough happy birthday
indeed i wish you luck in your next game
now well if i stay in this game will it
be possible to reconnect with you guys
sure man of course oh man
oh no i was too far away to help
i send you friend requests so may as
well do a squad or something
hmm oh yeah you sent me one right
yeah i did and uh to markiplier too
oh all right oh thank you i'll look into
that as soon as i'm dead which will
probably be soon
[Laughter]
wait isn't markiplier a youtuber i
don't know about that would you happen
to be the youtuber markiplier
uh i can neither confirm nor deny
any such insinuations i would say yes
then
well
sounds cool to me i do check a lot of a
youtube page about video game and stuff
and your voice does sound familiar
oh i don't know maybe i just got one of
those voices the voice is every people
have a nice video voice yeah about that
too
we got a whole bunch of teammates just
over at loot lake for some reason i'm
not sure why
i like i guess he likes women yeah
oh and by the way if you guys do have a
hard time death
understanding me sometimes it's because
i'm a french canadian so oh my apology
i will hold that against you what did
you say mark huh
i said i hate you for that it's it's the
one thing i can't stand i'm an
incredible racist oh really
yeah just a true fact about me sorry i
tried to be honest about my racism
though it's just
keep it open you know that way
everything's fine hey i'm white
no no i'm racist against pretty much
everybody anybody that's not explicitly
me i'm
racist against okay so you're just like
everybody
yeah i hate everybody so you're kind of
dr house
yes that except racist i want to
emphasize on my incredible horrible
racism
[Laughter]
that's okay you must be from texas then
i can either confirm nor deny my texas
upbringing
okay apparently i made some friends so
that's nice it's someone's birthday and
they're hanging around even though
they're dead and they're terrible
teammates but whatever it's all good
so i'm guessing since you're saying that
you hate everybody except you
i guess you would be the kind of guy who
would put a bullet in the back of your
body
well that's awfully presumptuous of you
no no no i may be a horrible racist but
i'm no murderer
can't these people tell the difference
well i'm saying actually in the game
no i was talking in real life yeah oh
may as well be that dude like i don't
know your background
how much of this game do you play
markiplier yeah it just started i don't
really know anything about it just heard
the 50 50 mode was here and i thought
i'd check it out so
seemed pretty fun and you're still alive
surprisingly i guess you got luckier
than i
well well we'll see how that luck holds
out
i imagine it won't because our team
seems to be down a few
you saying you're not going to pull a
1v30
i wasn't planning on it i believe i
don't believe in me i don't believe
i don't believe in me at all no no way
that's in addition to my incredible
racism i have
crippling self-doubt i have no
self-confidence what's up whatsoever but
the way you do speak you actually sounds
like
you know those kind of boys which are
overconfident
yeah that does sound like me
oh my dome got shot
oh from the right
ouchy ouch someone's raising you up
someone's been tasty
yeah i don't know they they seem to be
focused on themself which is obviously a
priority in my opinion
oh well well there you go
save yourself oh no that's not good
oh i'll block your bullets with my body
my body my beautiful body
my body my body hey we're all dead now
hey yeah we're dead okay all right i'm
i'm out here
see you guys i'm recording a video i
gotta keep going all right find another
one
oh bye well aren't they delightful happy
birthday to whatever his name was i
wasn't even paying attention to that
i'm going to try again let's do it again
all right another game another game wow
okay i just watched them
die oh no oh
no all righty then
who's on my team who's not on my team
and where are we gonna go
i just put down a marker i don't know if
anybody's actually gonna go for it but
nope my teammate has gone not that way
okay all right well kills is gonna go
for the rambo kills
which i can respect hey hey
hey hi
okay all right we got him we got him
calm down calm down calm your murderous
rage
shield potion for some reason
ow who did the ow what the heck my
shield potion
no my ass my ass how did you get how did
you
oh my god manooks god damn it
i'm dead like an [ __ ] is that what i
am dead
like an [ __ ] and there's kills off on
her own
man fine another match
i got to win one of these man the first
two games i played before i started
recording i was doing wonderfully and i
re
everything went great and everything was
super fun and happy and
now not so much oddly enough not so much
but i'm gonna do this again i got this
dude
that okay
i got a gun i got a gun i got a gun i
got a gun
[Music]
got him i'm out of ammo oh no kill me
or don't kill me don't kill me i want to
specify
oh boy here we go what are we going to
do everybody
what's going on ah i like it i can groo
i congruency with that oh yeah
ah the good [ __ ]
man you really glide you
really glide oh i'm about to hit a
bridge
nope going right through it apparently
okay all right then
oh wow okay well that's nowhere can i
get a gun
can i get a gun oh yeah i got a gun all
right
well i got a gun that's a thing got two
guns one's not good is the other gun but
i got
something okay all right you can have
that go for it
go for it get it teammate that i care
about
that i care about the survival of ooh
there you are shiny
okay i know how to get to you oh wait no
i don't have any materials all right
i'll do one of these maneuvers
come on
shield potion yeah yeah okay
we are far away all right well at least
i got a gun
that's good now if only i could do
something about that all right
autobots roll out indeed
let's see where we're gonna go for this
what do my elven eyes see
nothing probably enemies hmm smart
meeting up with more of our teammates i
see
ah yes excellent
i too will smash up this car for raw
resources
ah yes i see who's up here okay
thought i heard somebody ooh tomato town
all right that's weird
who built this okay gotta move on i
guess
i don't like it see it's like a balance
you gotta you gotta like one get guns
but also like
for the end game you also gotta get like
enough raw materials to be able to
build uh walls and bases and stuff like
that to be defensible and on the move
and all that [ __ ]
so if it was like super strategic team
battles
where everyone could actually
communicate with each other which they
can't
you know they'd be like hey you can't
you guys go gathering you guys go
scavenger who got who got shot taco
supreme
oh taco supreme where are you i'll try
to get you oh he's oh he's so far off
oh he's in fatal fields i can't get him
in fatal fields
that was his stupid idea for going all
the way over there anyway
what a dummy what a dummy
okay it's getting down to the wire the
teams are actually evenly stacked this
time around so it's still anybody's game
it's not just defined right off the bat
but we shall see
pretty sure teammate built this whoa i
should have jumped
good old loot lake huh good old loot
lake
okay okay we do have a lot of teammates
over here which is nice
whoa [ __ ] that was my bad i scared
everybody didn't i
oopsies oh is that a scarecrow in the
sky oh it's beautiful
okay looks like we're assembling our
squad over here i see a bunch of them
over there which is good that bodes well
because that means that we
are all gathering up together and we
finally assembling
[Laughter]
nice bush i'm going to take this instead
oh dammit i meant instead not with i got
too many guns
all right looks like the the team is
moving this away
we're all i know we're just waiting for
the next circle to see where that's
going to be because
depending on where the circle is it's
either going to mean we cross the lake
or where
we're going to have to camp over here
and uh shrinky dink oh
we gotta cross the lake uh pleasant park
is gonna be the death ground all right
i'm down
you still got a lot of wood uh our guys
are getting picked off but also their
guys are getting picked off so
it stands 28 to 22 our team and i
haven't done [ __ ]
so whoa who where whoa who did that
well i don't like going up this big
thing but you know
i am a follower so i'm gonna follow up
or also i'm i'm gonna be stranded you
[ __ ] ass who did that son of a tit
son of a [ __ ] tit son of a titty [ __ ]
all right fine i don't need you you
think i need you
the answer is i do not need you
cause i have my own way to go
ah don't box me out i just built that
hey [ __ ] what are you doing
we're doing your douche f2 there we go
now we're looking like we got a thing we
know what we're doing about
yeah that's oh that's that's the good
stuff oh that is the good stuff
wait no no wait hang on wait reese wait
oh
god i i didn't mean to do this one
i forget how you cancel i don't god damn
it you [ __ ] who did this
all right wait oh hang on i edit this
put a door in there there we go okay
got it let me build you some chest eye
walls friend
all right well see this is the cool
thing like suddenly everyone just starts
slapping a tower together like out of
nowhere it's just like all right
this i decree this is where our base
shall be and nobody decided anything
i don't know where they are but i have a
funny feeling they're setting up on the
other side
which would be devastating oh boy
oh boy this is gonna be a doozy
oh [ __ ] well this base is all blunk we
gotta go forward
that's what i'm gonna do see my thing is
i just like to build as i go up
just to create like barricades and
fuselage and
yada yadas and fancy words just because
i'm like
who got hit b guy no
where'd b guy go down i don't know who
cares there's only 20 of them out there
i just walk out and suddenly there's
barricades everywhere
that's ingenuity right there that's
ingenuity okay this is weird
where are they where are they
by all accounts we should see them huh
guess we're trying to get the high
ground which is smart
oh that's not good that's close to me
that's very close to me
oh that's very close to me all right
what do we got what do we got what do we
got
guys trying to take shots oh that's
definitely one of their bases
oh there they are
whoop whoop whoop
whoo
oh we're losing we're low on peeps we're
low on people's
there's a lot of shusting happening
okay i'm gonna try to get down there try
to help this guy hey
no one shoot me please no one shoot me
i'm a hero i'm a hero right now
up and at him
who shot me
ah above us oh how'd they get above us
so quickly
oh boy oh boy
oh boy oh i'm in the storm oh
no i wasn't paying attention to the
storm if i
just run for it they would have been oh
no
oh 7v10 i gotta see how my team does
oh i didn't do [ __ ] i didn't do [ __ ]
that round
it was a terrible run oh no oh no what a
tough fight
tough fight oh man everyone just tries
it's so sad everyone tries
like no matter what everyone tries oh
boy build the
build spastically
i have the power to create oh [ __ ] and
now i'm dead
ty dazz g won the game why does tide sg
won the game that doesn't make any sense
at all
that seems unlikely
[Music]
i have no money oh i'm in the game
that's the other thing matchmaking a lot
quicker than this one which is nice but
they don't have a zombie mode which is
[ __ ] because i love zombie mode all
right where are we going
i agree oh well this is going to be a
tough
squabble
hell yeah oh this looks like an
important gun whoa hello
okay apparently i found everything so if
i die this time
around i am an [ __ ] officially like
unforgivably i'm a dick if i
if i [ __ ] this up somehow okay gotta
meet up with my teammates so i got a
shotgun an
assault rifle that's apparently
legendary or something and
a sniper rifle whoa and a submachine gun
that's always good and let me
drink my whatever the [ __ ] this slime
slug slime is
okay apparently i've got i've i got
decked out with absolutely everything
you could possibly get in some of the
best equipment
bar none and somehow i'm gonna find a
way to [ __ ] it up and die i know that
for a fact i'm not gonna die to the
circle that's for sure but it looks like
our whole team is in this town which is
lovely now i just gotta make sure i find
everything i need
ammo wise because if i don't then all of
this
is for nothing anyway shouldn't be the
first one to go over there oh i'll be
the first one to go over there okay here
i go
let's arrange on this scope oh
that's nice that's real nice
i'm not the best sniper though but here
i go
man those guys got to move we're we got
we got to get to the circle
okay i made it into the circle at least
that is something
see if i can get some high ground
oh come on oh [ __ ] one shot at a time
okay i get it
ah well that's okay there's a drop to it
oh almost gotcha he just moved he just
moved
well i can damn yeah this is
these are long shots they'd have to be
standing like stock still
oops okay only one bullet left on that
one so that was a waste i didn't hit
anybody but it felt good so that's what
matters
that was a good engagement for our bros
i guess
oof looks like we're just annihilating
the other team this can't be good
man i want to get at least one kill
prove that i'm worthy and whatnot
god damn it they're just making me run
the whole time
all day every day okay oh boy oh boy oh
boy i don't know if i'm gonna make this
i made a detour that was probably a bad
idea i'm gonna make it i'm gonna make it
i'll make it
come on i just want to be in the battle
i got all these good guns
please please please to
oh be now my good guns
oh boy oh man that was dicey
wow six health okay all right then i
have six health six health
oh boy but i gotta kill so that's good i
almost died doing it but hey i got a
kill
snuck that shot in there
yeah never that was pure luck but
oh all righty then
hey wow that ended everything quickly
i did it
that guy had an epic sniper but hey that
was good
i didn't use any of my amazing guns to
the best of my ability but hey
i still won and it felt good so thank
you everybody so much for watching
uh hope you enjoyed this i'll probably
play this again with my buddies
uh just as soon as they're free but i
just want to give it a try to give an
idea of it before i get into it with
them so thank you everybody so much for
watching
let me know what you think down the
comments below and as always i will see
you
in the next video bye-bye